(intense music)
- The Harvard Brain Bank is
one of the largest brain banks
in the country.
At the moment we house
approximately 5,000 brain specimens.
My name is Sabina Berretta,
I am the scientific director
of the Harvard Brain
Tissue Resource Center,
which we affectionately
call the Harvard Brain Bank.
Our mission is to collect brain specimens,
store them, categorize them, and
then redistribute them out
to investigators across
the world that do research
on the human brain, and in particular,
on large number of
neurological and psychiatric
brain disorders, such as
schizophrenia, bipolar disorder,
Parkinson, Huntington, and many others.
The Brain Bank never sleeps,
we have two sets of people
that are on call 24/7,
we have a very limited time window
from when the person passes away
to the time we need to be done
with this whole processing.
- So this is gonna be your first
brain late at night, right?
- I know, first late night brain.
- We have to do it in less than 24 hours.
Our courier will bring
it to McLean Hospital
to the brain bank.
- [Voiceover] So just put it out here,
so we're gonna take ourselves.
- There will be a dissectionist
ready to dissect the brain.
That involves, so separating
the two hemispheres,
one of the two hemispheres
is put in a solution
that preserves it, the other
hemisphere will be dissected
in thick sections, and
those will be frozen.
We are not even close to understand
a lot of what we take for granted.
Our thoughts, our instincts,
our feelings, our emotions.
There are a lot of questions
we still don't know,
and a lot of our brain functions
still will probably be studied
for a long time to come.
A brain donation is,
in a very concrete way,
a gift of knowledge and it
cannot be done without the help
of families and people
willing to donate their brain.
(gentle music)